so how did you come to this conclusion
that these two parties are not actually
trying to work in the people's interest
when did that click for you it clicked
for me over something very simplistic
andrew
the fact that they have built an entire
political system
based upon the concept of bribery the
only way you're going to get an audience
with any elected official
of a democrat or republican persuasion
is bring a check
you know don't bring your problem bring
a check with your problem
and then you'll at least get your
audience see they've turned our system
into a complete system of bribery and
what's weird about that is that if you
do that in the private sector you go to
jail
[Music]
it is my pleasure i want to say honor my
honor and privilege to welcome to
forward perhaps the greatest independent
politician
though he calls himself a statesman i
think that's accurate so the
independent statesman of our time former
governor of minnesota and a childhood
hero of mine jesse the body ventura
welcome jesse
hi andrew it's great to be here like i
said uh uh i saw you that first time at
the at the democratic convention and you
popped out to me immediately because i
immediately said this man is not going
to stay with the democrats for very long
and sure enough i was right again
yeah no it's it's it's wonderful to be
here andrew it's wonderful to hear about
the forward party movement in america
all i can say is good luck and anything
i can do to help i'm here well super
grateful and we're gonna need your help
we're gonna take you up on that in a big
way so on a personal note you just got a
new car is that right
yeah i i'm in a great mood i uh i got a
my new car was just delivered to me on
friday and uh it's a brand new tesla
and uh i'm 70 years old now and i can
proudly say i own the fastest car
currently on the planet i'll tell you
why i i drive i don't drive fast anymore
and i'm probably i won't even probably
break the speed limit that much with
this car
but i will admit to one thing
i'm a person who occasionally needs an
adrenaline rush
we all know that feeling that you
occasionally i gotta have that you know
i had 34 parachute jumps
i've done a lot of things in my life
that give me that type of adrenaline
rush
and the tesla can do that and i was
informed what's great about it
you can achieve that adrenaline rush on
the down ramp
i mean just going down to enter the
freeway
you can do it for that split second like
a ride at the fair
but uh i need that and it's just kind of
fun to do it and and the other reason
andrew is i wanted to eliminate my
carbon footprint personally
uh this is my second tesla i bought my
wife one i got her the uh the little
hatchback
and uh i did my entire home solar
three years ago
and for the last two years
xl energy in february sends me a check
so i get all my electricity from the sun
on my house now
and now i have all my electricity that
powers my two teslas likewise come from
the sun
so the sun is powering my house and my
cars and i'm extremely proud of that you
know
whether it'll pay me back in the long
run i don't know i don't care i'm you
know at my age but i feel good about it
that jesse ventura is not
contributing to climate change yeah
you've been a champion of the
environment um as a political
independent since before it was cool so
i i referenced your being a childhood uh
idol of mine which you were from your
days as a wwe commentator uh i don't
know if you saw that i kind of you
didn't like you were you didn't like my
wrestling so your rest your wrestling
predated me a little bit wait wait don't
just limit me to a commentator you know
andrew i actually stepped into the ring
for 13 14 plus years oh i i i know that
you were a wrestler but uh you know your
wrestling predated my um
my fandom
by a little
let me clarify that only because i got
injured
yeah
the night before i was due to wrestle
hogan for the world for the wwf
championship is when i went down to
blood clots in my lungs which derailed
my wrestling career otherwise i would
have gone around the entire circuit with
hogan and you would have been much more
aware of my wrestling but because of an
injury that curtailed me and then of
course i fell into the broadcasting end
but continue i'm sorry no not at all i
mean you you were in my view the best
broadcaster uh you had your
sense of humor uh you know built in uh
you had your own perspective
um and i don't know if you saw but when
i was running for president i ran a foul
of vince mcmahon by uh calling for
better treatment of wrestlers or
performers um i think there should be an
association over a union um i think it's
exploitative what's going on with that
and i'm friends with a number of uh
wrestlers and performers it seems that
you predated me on that by a number of
decades
yeah no way way back when
uh during when wrestlemanias were just
starting we had just had wrestlemania
one
and we were still in a huge battle with
the charlotte territory for who was
going to be number one we were number
one because of wrestlemania the first
one but they were barking at our heels
they had ric flair they had a lot of
terrific talent down there in in the nwa
at the time and atlanta with wcw
and so uh it was we were approaching
wrestlemania two
and that was the one where we were going
to be in three different places la
chicago and i think long island if i my
recollection's correct i was in the la
one
it had always bothered me as a wrestler
that we had we
well let me backtrack there i had been
on an elevator
with in vegas
and onto the elevator came gene upshaw
the former old fall pro
hall of fame guard of the oakland
raiders
and big gene got on that elevator and we
recognized each other said hi to each
other first thing out of big gene's
mouth to me he pointed big lifted up
that big finger of his into the air and
he says you boys in wrestling need a
union because see he was head of the
national football league's player
association he was their union head at
the time
i looked at him gene i said you're
you're speaking to the crowd that agrees
with you you know you're damn right we
do and so that stuck in me and when i
went to mania or this wasn't mania when
i went to the event
that night
all of the people from the office were
out of the room in the locker room and i
stood up on the chair and i said guys
now is the time we can unionize
i said all the publicity has gone out on
wrestlemania two all we have to do is
stick together go to the press and say
we are refusing to wrestle unless union
people are brought in and we're allowed
to talk to them i said federal law
grants us that
i said they would have to break federal
law to stop us i was pleading with them
and one guy yelled out well we need
hogan i said no we don't i said all we
need is bundy that's who he's wrestling
hogan's got to wrestle somebody he can't
wrestle a broomstick
you know and so i said as long as
bundy's on board with us all of us and
then let's get a hold of charlotte let's
get a hold of the boys down in atlanta
unless all we have to do is say we are
not wrestling unless we're allowed to
unionize i said who do you think runs
these buildings union people they turn
the lights on they do all the mate they
do they run the buildings if they honor
our request
we could shut down vince's wrestlemania
until he lets us unionize
so
i gave my speech
i flew home that night the next day my
phone rang vince
well uh jesse
what's this you getting on the high
horse union
reads me out for it and i came back at
him and i said well vince i'm not
talking about a union just to fight you
i said i'm talking about benefits i said
right now i pay over 5 000
a year for health care for me and my
kids
i said if i had a union that price would
drop
i said i see all these old wrestlers who
now
don't have a pot to piss in or a window
to throw it out of they spent 20 25
years in this business and it rewards
them with nothing i said vince we're not
financial planners we're wrestlers
i said we we're not the greatest at
looking to the future and seeing what we
need to do today in order to someday if
we reach 60 years old
i said that's what we need a union for
and so vince you know did that edit and
so what it was andrew here's what
happened i was immediately leaving to
new predator so i if vince then wouldn't
let me and i had to quit i quit and went
did predator but
in order to do predator i had to join
the screen actors guild
i now had a union
so when i then came back to vince i said
to him during the negotiations i said
well vince i said you don't have to
worry about me yelling about the union
no more he said oh really why not i said
i got mine i said if the rest of these
guys are too chicken [ __ ] or don't want
to put it up to stand up for it i'm not
gonna get my head cut off no more i got
my union i'm a member of the screen
actors guild and will be till i retire
and i get health benefits from them
everything everything that you won't
provide they do
so you don't have to worry i'm not going
to do that well
later on when i sued vince for royalties
and beat him
during the depositions i told my
attorneys
because you can ask about anything
in a deposition i said i told them the
whole story and i had great attorneys i
said if you can find out
please find out who ratted me
who was the guy who of the wrestlers
ratted me out that day that i stood up
and tried to unionize or offered them
the ability to balls it out and see if
we could do it yep so during the
deposition my attorney goes well mr
mcmahon he goes on
other sports have unions he goes is
there is there a union in wrestling and
vince of course answers no under oath
uh my attorney goes well
has anyone ever tried to form a union in
wrestling
and vince had a moment and paused and he
goes well yeah he said i think and he
pointed to me across the table i think
uh yeah i think jesse ventura spouted
his mouth off about it once or whatever
i seem to remember that and my attorney
said well did you hear mr ventura do
this
and vince goes no and my attorney said
well then how do you know he did and
with no hesitation
hulk hogan told me
then he also admitted it on
on larry king because vince got on larry
king and larry brought it back up saying
the thing about union is it true that it
was halt and vince admitted there that
it was hulk hogan
to told him well here's why hulk ratted
us and why hope didn't want a union
later on during my court case with
mcmahon we had through discovery the
entire payoff of wrestlemania 3.
now andrew that's the big one in the
pontiac silver dome where we broke the
world's record
savage steamboat i remember it well
yeah versus hogan right
well we got the list here's why hogan
didn't want a union
because i saw how everyone got paid for
wrestlemania 3
hulk hogan got more money than all the
rest of us combined
so if you're including andre so if you
included andre and every other wrestler
who was on wrestlemania 3 hogan got paid
more than all of us combined now if
there was a union
something like that would not happen
because you couldn't see a disparity to
that level
i mean andre should have been paid equal
to hogan sir they're the same match they
were the same draw
but you can bet who'd went to the bank
that day the boy who was being taken
care of because there wasn't any union
so that showed me clearly why hogan
didn't want a union
because he was getting taken care of
and now a word from our sponsor
better help it's the summer but that
doesn't mean that we still don't get
down in the dumps and the fact is our
friends and family members really are
not equipped to lend the kind of help
that some of us need i first saw a
therapist in my teens and i immediately
sensed that this is something that's
going to be good for my frame of mind
and i've been a huge believer in therapy
and getting professional help ever since
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your new therapist so
you don't have to see anyone on camera
if you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours from the comfort of your
own home
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
yang that's better h h-e-l-p
dot com slash yang go and get better
help today
[Music]
so did that end up affecting your
relationship with hogan because you guys
are friends oh yeah
never have taught have i talked to him
make sense
yeah and when i learned that i thought
well he's an old the only friend he has
is himself
you know that's that's who his friend is
and i thought so no i've not spoken to
him a funny story uh here's another good
one for you andrew
later on when i was governor and i get a
call from vince mcmahon and then what
the hell's vince calling me i mean this
is 19 2000 whenever the hell it was i
hadn't even been it's been a decade
hogan is on the book tour and he's
supposed to come to minneapolis
hogan is now worried because i'm
governor
that you know he got in some trouble
here
where he was accused of sexual assault i
don't even know what how they bought
their way out of it in the end or
whatever prevailed i never kept track of
it the call from vince was because hogan
had fear
that if he came to minnesota that i as
governor would have him arrested you
know what i told vince andrew what
please tell hogan this is directly from
the governor of the state of minnesota
that i have far more important things to
deal with
than whatever hulk hogan in his little
world happens to be doing
and i said give that message to him
personally i'm sure vince delivered it
well you know i got i got the dems to
deal with the republicans that deal with
probably a budget who knows everything
you know let me assure you andrew when
you're the governor of the state your
plate's full
oh yeah i bet so you leave then the wwf
in the uh late 80s early 90s you become
mayor of a town in minnesota sixth
largest city
sixth largest city and then you run for
governor and win against all odds no one
sees it coming
uh you saw it coming you had a really
unconventional campaign
advertising
voting against politics as usual which
you know i dare say makes you something
of a pioneer trailblazer because i think
people have been fed up with politics as
usual since at least 1998 which is when
this election was and you you won so
when that campaign was going on
um people gave you very very long odds
did you see the the path to victory yes
i did because uh i always saw a path of
victory and here's my here's the path in
my opinion andrew minnesota generally
leads the nation in voter turnout
it's always between us and maine
when angus king was gov independent
governor of maine and i was the
independent governor of minnesota we'd
always have a bet
who was going to have the higher voter
turnout in the in the and minnesota
would always prevail by a percentage
point or two so minnesota generally
leads the nation in voter turnout but
that wasn't what compelled me to believe
i could win our voter turnout is so
pathetic
in the united states of america
here's what they predicted my election
year it was non-presidential they
predicted a 50
voter turnout and that's the voter
turnout that leads the nation
so andrew i went into this election like
i did wrestling
i went in going 50 of the people of
minnesota are potentially there for my
vote
all i have to do is motivate this 50
percent
that's out there that is not voting to
simply take an hour of their time and go
vote and it don't cost them nothing
you know
and it turned out i was identi
absolutely correct do you know what the
voter turned out in my election after
all the experts predicted it would be a
50
voter turnout because it was
non-presidential
i'm going to say 65
no not that high just 60. still that's a
lot higher but that 10
andrew i was polling 27
the day before the election
that 10
they didn't count on took me to 37 and i
won
so i knew that i had a pool of voters
out there half of minnesota
was available for me to defeat these
guys that's how bad they are well you
were spot on there and you served as
governor through one term didn't run for
reelection in part because you had a
very combative relationship with the
media which is something i can relate to
uh there are a lot of things about your
career that i i think are remarkable and
you're now one of the
preeminent leaders and thinkers on
independent politics
so a lot of folks look up and say hey
third parties can't compete um you ran
under the reform party banner is that
right uh yes we were the independence
party first senator dean barkley
ran in on that in a statewide race and
as an independence party candidate he
got over five percent which is the
quality qualification mark in minnesota
if the party gets a statewide candidate
that gets over five percent you have
major party status
so we were the independence party of
minnesota then of course came the rise
up of ross perot's reform party out of
texas
and so we affiliated with them for about
two years until we realized it wasn't
truly a third party movement it was
simply a ross perot movement
he he wouldn't let it expand or grow
beyond him so i we then disaffiliated
when i was governor back to being the
independence party of minnesota so yes i
was elected and was the highest ever i
think elected official from the then
reform party of america but we were the
independence party before and ended up
the independence party again by the time
i got out of office
so let's say someone's trying to
replicate the conditions of your race uh
so you had a few advantages
one you were famous
you're infamous or infamous
[Laughter]
you had a very very clear public persona
um you were a national figure and
presence i remember hearing about your
winning uh that race and it being
national news i mean it was a big deal
so if people who are
trying to follow in your footsteps
and they look up and say okay how can we
recreate the conditions so minnesota is
an above average environment uh it's got
a real uh strain of independent voting
and its history and a high turnout uh
you're a singular candidate there are
other candidates who are trying to make
the same magic happen i'll call out one
uh betsy johnson who's running as an
independent in
oregon uh this fall i don't suppose you
know betsy i i don't think i don't think
i've met her i don't know but i might be
wrong no no it's fine so for those
people who are looking at uh that
particular race like i think betsy's got
a real shot at it she's polling
somewhere in the 20s
uh she's raised a lot of money because
people are fed up with politics as usual
but there hasn't been uh as i'm thinking
about it um someone else who's done what
you've done
uh since your victory is that correct
has there been another independent
governor
well there there was an independent
governor right with me he just never got
pressed and he's now a u.s senator
independent from maine angus king
yeah he caucuses with the democrats
angus does and and angus is a good
friend of mine you know because uh the
fun story when at the national governors
association when you all go out to
washington and go meet the president and
all that
well on the second day out there andrew
they have a building where all the
republican governors beat this building
all the democratic governors meet in
that building well that left angus and
me
and they didn't accommodate us there was
nothing there was nothing there wasn't a
third building yeah there wasn't there
was nothing done to accommodate angus
and i
so what we did we walked down
constitution avenue
sat down on the park bench on a
beautiful sunny day and we caucused
right there and the fun part was all the
media followed us
we had the media
12 deep
with me and angus king because i was the
spotlight anyway and i'm there with
angus the other independent governor and
we announced this is the independent
governor caucus
and we said please step back far enough
so angus and i can talk in private and
not be overheard by media because we'd
want the same type of thing you're not
allowed in their caucuses so we don't
want you overhearing what we talk about
there could be personal things who knows
yeah that makes total sense and you too
would be a much more fascinating
uh convo
so getting back to what you said andrew
is yes there was there is another
example of an independent candidate
angus king who won the state of maine
multiple times
yeah and and he doesn't get the press he
deserves i agree
you had something of a contentious
relationship with the press when you
were governor you actually credited that
as one reason why um you didn't
necessarily want to serve a second term
because they put a lot of pressure on
your
family members your personal life i had
some experience with this myself when i
ran for mayor of new york city the press
was really
uh very adversarial and
odd
oh yeah
and there was part of me that was like
you know i think that there's just some
institutional resistance to any figure
that they consider an outsider uh who
comes into power did you experience the
same thing and in your case it'd be even
more bizarre because you'd been a mayor
for a number of years prior
oh yeah it was it was very difficult i i
but i had a cantankerous relationship to
the press and i gave it back to them as
much as they gave it to me
you know so our relationship because i
made them all where i made officially
they all had to wear badges that said
media jackal that's pretty funny so they
had to walk
and if they didn't have it they didn't
get in
they had to wear it because governor has
the power to do that
and then well i'll give you a few fun
examples
that'll make you laugh
i had a
sit-down meeting with the dalai lama he
came to see me i mean i was honored
after i got to know him and realized
he's a wonderful man and has a sense of
humor
i asked him if he'd ever seen the movie
caddyshack
because there's that famous scene with
bill murray
where he talks about caddying for the
dalai lama a big hitter
it's a whole hilarious scene from
caddyshack and i asked the dalai lama if
he'd ever seen the movie and he said he
hadn't my son was so embarrassed he left
the room
because he knew i told him before that i
was going to ask him if he ever saw
caddyshack well anyway getting back to
the press
um when it came time for the dalai lama
to leave
uh we have a thing at the minnesota
capital
a secret way you can shuttle someone out
of the governor's office and get them
out of the building where the press
don't know about it and that's what i
did with the dalai lama i didn't want
him to have to deal with
the jackals so we got him out of there
and i went out and met with him and i
walked out and they gave me
they gave me the greatest lead line a
comedian could ever get and that was now
think back to the movie that was well
governor
what did the dalai lama say to you
and i couldn't resist
i looked at the media and i said well
the dalai lama told me gunda gunda
lagunga
which means when i die i'll have total
consciousness so i got that going for me
and i turned around and went in and
that's all i had for a press conference
the only press guy
was the guy from uh public
radio
eric estella
sitting down by hold his mic like that
he'd sit down here
his mic started shaking because he
started laughing so hard he got it and
that was the end of the press conference
one of the things that i admired about
your term is that you had a habit of
sending
minnesotans rebates uh because your
government had a surplus
uh what how much were those rebates like
how much were families getting
oh there were families getting some some
up to 2 500
or more
it all depended on this here's here's
the rebate thing
when i got that's what compelled me to
run
i was doing statewide talk radio
we had a budget previous to me getting
there where they had billions of dollars
in extra money why did they have that
first and foremost the economy was
powerful remember the 90s
clinton
yeah yeah you had a powerful economy
back then i mean the wheels were rolling
everybody's making money
well and obviously because of such a
robust economy
minnesota's taxing too much
so their taxing brought in more money
than what they budgeted for
they brought in so much revenue they had
billions of dollars too much and what
did they do they spent it like kids in
the candy store
it was their birthday and they got a big
monetary present i ran on that here came
the budget surplus again
i then here was my fight with
republicans they didn't have a problem
with what i wanted to do but they wanted
to do it in a income tax rebate
so that one third of our money would go
to the federal government
i said let's do it in a sales tax rebate
you can't write off a sales tax so
therefore people will get a check they
don't have to declare it
well
it's their money andrew you think
they're not going to spend it of course
they are and what's that going to do get
the economy going
they're spending money they got money to
spend and it's free money it's their
money
and you know they're how many are going
to bank it maybe a few
maybe some put it to school loan i don't
know but uh it's their money but i
finally convinced the republicans to do
it in a sales tax rebate and here's what
it was based upon
it was based upon your income
if you're worth this much we figured out
okay here's about how much you'd spend
and this is about how much your sales
tax would be
and that's the way we did it i think
everybody got at least a grand
or something like that i don't even
remember i'd have to go back and see
but it was based upon your income but it
was given back as a sales tax rebate we
copied i think it was the state of
colorado had done that with something in
order to keep the fed's hands off the
money because it wasn't their money to
begin with it was minnesota's money why
would we want to give the federal
government a third of it
[Music]
one of the weaknesses of the system
right now jesse is that in my mind you
have liz cheney and adam kinzinger and
other people who are trying to stand up
within the republican party and the vast
majority of democrats are just painting
all republicans with a certain brush
maybe they're they're saying like hey
um you know yeah good for them but no
one's really doing anything to try and
preserve let's say in this case yeah
this chaney seat and the rest of it um
so the republican party is getting
overrun in the very few figures another
guy who stood up and and voted to
impeach trump who's also up for
re-election who has better chances uh
peter meyer in in michigan
and you know like they're they're
demonstrating courage on a level that i
don't think most people appreciate um
and democrats are not helping them
because of just this bizarre
polarization in the system where they
look at and be like ah you know like all
republicans are bad even the ones that
in this case are trying to fight to
preserve
uh democracy in the face of trump i
think that the most dangerous thing we
have right now andrew is not the it's
not the republicans in congress i
believe right now the most dangerous
thing we have
is that for sure
we have two dishonorable liars on the
supreme court yeah that i mean the
entire country has been uh very very
inflamed over the recent decision which
i disagree with no the liars not even
there
and the fact that they they lied about
they lied to you on the way in andrew
let me put it to you this way you're a
private sector guy you have been pretty
much your whole life if you go in with a
job application
and on that job application most of them
ask this question have you ever been
convicted of a felony
now let's say you have
but you decide i'm gonna lie and check
no
okay you get the job then
and six months to a year goes by and the
company finds out through whatever that
you lied that yes you are a convicted
felon andrew i'll bet dollars to donuts
you would be terminated immediately
yeah from your job for lying on the
application
gaining the job and who could possibly
trust you again
if you lied at that level you would be
better off admitting you were the felon
that you were convicted saying look i
want to do right i want to fix myself
you'll get some sympathy they would
probably hire you more by being truthful
than they would they'd fire you if they
knew you lied
well you would definitely get fired for
a misrepresentation even if it's
relatively trivial in your job
application that's true you wrote a book
that characterized the two major parties
um as two gangs and i had a really funny
title it was uh the demo crips and the
robloticans
which i think is hysterical
but you have been
making this case that the two-party
system is uh destroying us or tearing us
apart for years you've had direct
experience running a state and uh having
to navigate both of those parties
and you've been affiliated with some of
the other uh third-party movements in
this country right now you and i are
aligned with the fact that we need a
third-party movement uh you and i are
going to team up on it and make it
happen and i'm firmly convinced that
uh the opportunity has never been bigger
uh really even you know in our lifetimes
so how did you come to this conclusion
that these two parties are not actually
trying to work in the people's interest
when did that click for you it clicked
for me over something very simplistic
andrew
the fact that they have built an entire
political system
based upon the concept of bribery the
only way you're going to get an audience
with any elected official
of a democrat or republican persuasion
is bring a check
you know don't bring your problem bring
a check with your problem
and then you'll at least get your
audience see they've turned our system
into a complete system of bribery and
what's weird about that is that if you
do that in the private sector you go to
jail
but here in the public sector it's
standard operating procedure
it doesn't make any sense
and why do we want a system based upon
money and who pays off the politician
and because of that system it then
becomes a system within them
of holding power it becomes all the
stuff with the the redistricting and all
of the garbage that goes with it and the
other reason these two parties that i
want them gone
is because of a very simple premise and
we're seeing it today so clearly andrew
they put their party before the country
yep
there's only two people i'm commending
today from the republican party and i
can't one of them i know i would but the
other one i can't believe i do and
that's liz cheney
oh yeah
because liz cheney i may not agree with
her and be the ultra conservative she is
and i got a lot of beef with her old man
but other than that liz cheney is
showing what you're supposed to do and
that is when it come when push comes to
shove
the country comes before the party i
wish mccarthy thought that i wish mitch
mcconnell thought that and i wish these
other power brokers had an inkling
of thinking that putting country before
party but that doesn't enter into their
thinking yeah liz cheney's showed a lot
of uh courage and people and she may
lose
and right now she's a pretty significant
underdog um in her reelection campaign
i've been tracking
the
trajectories of the republicans who
voted either to impeach trump or to
oppose in some way and it's really
really dark man i think there were 10
members of congress
that voted to impeach and by the way
that number was something like 35 just
minutes or hours before the vote was
taken and then all of them were getting
death threats on their phone and so the
number went from 35 it's a little bit
like wrestlers trying to unionize a
little bit i'd imagine so so it it went
from 35 to 25
to 15 and by the time the vote was
happening no one even knew uh who was
going to vote for it so you wound up
with just 10 and of those 10 um four
have retired and one has left
um and one of the retires is adam
kinzinger who's been very very vocal um
in his role but liz cheney is sticking
around or trying to stick around i
actually said that if liz cheney wants
me to i will go to wyoming in her
district and campaign for her
and i didn't ever believe i would ever
do that for liz cheney but in this case
i would because i admire her and the
courage she's showing in doing the right
thing when you talk about why did all
these other people run and hide what do
you expect when you get a criminal
running the operation a guy who has no
scruples whatsoever
a guy who puts himself first before the
country always
and and when we've got 30 percent of
this country that thinks that's
wonderful and see i got a beef with him
too we're talking about trump yeah where
the hell where the hell was he andrew
during vietnam
i i think he had a very serious medical
condition jesse yeah it's called bone
spurs
i mean i'm
joking i mean he's yeah yeah that's what
he had he had bone spurs in his feet
and that kept him out of the draft you
notice it didn't keep him off a golf
course for his entire life
see you got a coward this guy when it
was his time to serve and his time to
put his ass on the line
and i i challenge people i don't think
donald trump has ever even been in a
fight in his life i mean a physical fist
fight i don't believe he ever has and
yet he tells oh kick his butt remember
when he stands up there at the podium
and orders people around to beat people
up and all that this guy's nothing but a
thug
that's all he is nothing more i'll call
it like it is i'm jesse ventura anytime
hey
vince wants a wrestlemania
how about me and trump in the cage we'd
all pay to see that
so
you've been a champion of the third
party movement uh in part because you
characterize these two parties as
uh as corrupt um which i think most
americans are waking up to and
you've
flirted with running for president
several times since
then how close have you come what's the
closest you've come uh the closest i've
come
two times
the first time was after i had only
taken office in minnesota and i had
flown to new york on some type of
business that was before the 2000
election but by the year
doran bush
and i'll never forget it was the middle
of the night i'm traveling in a limo to
a hotel in downtown manhattan and i had
the window down
and
the new york construction guys were out
there working on a road in manhattan on
the street and we pulled up and stopped
and my window was down one of the
construction guys looked over and saw it
was me
and he stopped what he was doing he
walked over and he pointed right at me
and he says
the wrong governor's running for
president
and i thought oh my god this is a guy
working on the street in the middle of
the night in manhattan
and he sees me and tells me i'm the
governor that should be running for
president
in manhattan new york i'm from minnesota
and uh that was a time and i couldn't do
it because
i have my own moral conviction that i
promised the people of minnesota i
wanted to be their governor yeah i had
not completed that job i will never seek
another job in politics while i
currently hold one
unless it's the same one
unless it's for re-election that would
be but i would never
halfway through one job
go to seek a better one
baloney you have to you have to fulfill
your obligation and the promise you made
to the people who elected you it's that
plain and simple the other time was most
recently
when i dabbled with the green party
and there it became what a mess
i learned the green party was completely
fractured into two separate entities
it would have required me to repair
this two party and i was only getting
backed by one half not the other half
i would have had to try to repair that
half
put them both together and then in the
meantime quick run in and take on the
democrats and republicans with the
broken split party
jesse might be dumb but he's not stupid
and there was no way even i could
accomplish that andrew and i thought
this was a joke and they they wouldn't
and i'll never forget fox news
threw me in their poll
they threw me in with the two names i
was already polling 18 and the greenies
wouldn't go for it yeah one of the
things that people may not realize is
how
fractious
third parties are oh
where you get in there and you see that
that it's people pulling in different
directions
it's factions andrew there's a term for
it
the third parties is calling herding
cats
well it's been one fascinating and fun
thing about building the forward party
is that we're trying to build
uh the coalition i joke sometimes about
it being like lord of the rings the
gathering of the tribes because
different people have been looking at
the set of issues and my argument which
i know you agree with is like look we
have to change the mechanics so that
new parties can actually compete against
the duopoly and so you might disagree
with me on this or that or the other
thing it doesn't matter like until we
actually reform this system
we should
table all that stuff
together out there
the old cliche
of my old friend at russian television
it's the big picture
they got we need to look at the big
picture and the big picture is a third
choice
yep
we just need to get that third choice on
ballots around the country and form a
real competitive
third-party movement uh and then i think
we can contend and even win faster than
most people imagine because so many
people are fed up but you know 62
percent of americans want a third party
58 percent don't want either trump or
biden uh and so one of the things that
we are looking very hard at and you
could play a huge part in this is having
a third party primary for 2024 where we
bring in people
uh who just raise their hand and say
look like i'm running for president i
think americans deserve more than these
two choices
and then we have our own process our own
debates our own interviews and it's
actually fair like every american who
wants to participate can participate uh
in terms of voting and supporting and i
think whoever emerges from that process
whether it would be you or someone else
i think that they'd have so much organic
support because everyone would have seen
them actually compete in a fair process
and we kind of know that like there's a
fix in on the dnc there's a fix in and a
different way in the rnc
uh so if there's this forward party
nomination process like i suspect that
jesse ventura is going to be at one of
these podiums well i'll say this to you
andrew and i told you this before off
off the record or on my show maybe i
said it there you get me that ballot
access in 50 states that's what i need
to see
because you've got to get the ballot
access in 50 states
then the next step is get into the
debates
that's though it's that simple ballot
access getting the debates if that
happens
these two parties can be defeated it's
that simple
yes amen uh so you should know that
we're working on ballot access right now
the debates is in many ways the easier
part um so the official requirements to
get in the debates are 15 in national
polls and i'm very confident that
whoever emerges yeah but wait andrew if
it's 15 and you're at 16 they'll raise
it to 20. oh yeah no they'd have some
shenanigans but one of the other no no
they do that they they they adjust their
rates accordingly
well you know one of my my great
concerns jesse is like i'm not sure
whether debates uh will take place in
the way we're accustomed to because the
republicans have already said they're
boycotting um debates i don't know if
you saw that and then
and then one of the things i was saying
is like you know what's going to get the
republicans to show up is if you have a
third party candidate because then you
usually have like you know that like
let's say joe and then
um like a third candidate and then the
republican candidate would be like oh
gosh i got to show up or else americans
are going to get confused to think that
it's these two
andrew you see me
i know what i'm doing
i guarantee you if i'm there i'll get
trump to show up
it's true i'll i'll hit him so hard he
won't know what hit him i'll shame him
he'll leave her he would either have to
run power and hide
or show up and face me
[Laughter]
again millions of americans would tune
into that did you um did you know trump
from the wwe days i don't know if you
guys are i knew him i knew him from the
wwe days and he personally came and
visited and congratulated me when i won
governor
because we actually entertained him as a
possible presidential candidate
because the donald trump that came and
met with me in 98
is not the donald trump who ran in 2016.
the donald trump that well the donald
trump that met with me was giving money
to the democrats he was pro-choice yeah
he was you know he he had a total
different aspect and see that's what
shows you he's phony because he takes
the route that suits him
not truly a root that he believes in
i'd like to ask this andrew sure and
we're only speculating here let's have
some fun
do you believe someone like donald trump
and his background having three wives
and all the womanizing he's done in his
life
do you believe for a moment and i'm only
speculating do you think donald trump
could have ever been involved in an
abortion
stories are coming out right now saying
that i mean where he paid a woman off
that he impregnated some woman at one of
his affairs or whatever and that she got
pregnant and she came to him quietly and
they took care of the business i mean i
find that that's seems very plausible to
me when you look at his lifestyle and
the things we'll remember his famous
quote about the women where you grab
them
yeah i'm
sure that there's been a lot of uh let's
say you know i'm only speculating no no
i mean most of us would agree with you
on this um to to the
point you raised on ballot access in
many ways that is the the hurdle um but
it's it's very
it's very achievable uh each state has
different rules i mean you went through
the minnesota version of it uh there are
10 to 15 states that we think we can get
on the ballot of um this calendar year
22. uh and then by the end of 23
we'd be looking at something like uh you
know like twice that number maybe 30. so
we we can get there by 24 so i i've i've
seen the numbers i've seen the map um
this is all much more achievable than
it's been at any other point
andrew how much danger do you think we'd
face if say i won and we got our
electoral slates on changing them how
hard do you think the republicans would
try to
change the electoral slate then and send
different electorates
i mean
i would love for us to be in position to
find out my friend no that's what i'm
saying that as having fun with it you
know gee imagine if i won how quick
they'd change those electrics
now people who keep up with me jesse
know that uh you know i i think we're in
deep trouble now um and so i think that
a positive unifying third party movement
uh is
what the country needs really like you
know you have these two
uh warring parties that are both getting
um more and more
negative and hateful really in their own
in their own ways
yeah so if we can bring people together
and you've been one of the great
unifying figures that's why i cho that's
why i chose to talk to you because
you're a go-getter and my feelings
towards you andrew if anyone can do it
it's you
if anyone has the ability out there and
has the drive and the smarts and the
knowledge
you're the hope i saw well thank you
that means the world to me and here and
you're doing it now and so that's why
i'm on with you today because i want to
say that you got my support i'll support
whatever you do with the forward party
to get a third choice to this country as
quickly as possible in as many elections
as we can possibly get them in let's get
it because i i agree with you
the country is you know i i i served my
country and i took an oath
to honor the constitution and defend it
against all enemies foreign and domestic
and we have a lot of domestic enemies to
the constitution right now and the only
way of defeating them
is by winning at the ballot and with
elections and taking control of our
government back amen one american to
another thank you for your service and
let's do it jesse so pumped to have your
support and we are just skimming the
surface of what the forward party is
going to become um so i'm super amped to
have you aboard and uh and thrilled to
consider you a friend an ally this is
awesome you can hear me on here see me
and all that on sub stack die first then
quit that's the name of my show and you
know where that comes from don't you
andrew that's a navy seal slogan in
training die first then quit
[Music]
and for me what it means is
i'll have to die before i stop talking
i'm gonna keep talking and then i'll
i'll quit when i'm dead leave it to the
navy seals to have an even gnarlier
slogan then i ain't got time to bleed
[Laughter]
it's gnarlier die first then quit thank
you andrew i want to thank you very much
for having me on let's do it again let's
keep talking absolutely yeah let's do it
and do check jesse out on sub stack i've
i've seen him in his work he's working
with his son on some great stuff and
we'll see jesse again both on this
podcast and around the country we're
gonna head your way to minnesota before
too long keep the nose to the grinder
man you're the hope thank you brother
you and me both talk to you soon
you